who are you
not who you think i am
i'm going back to the very beginning of
the mcu we have a keystone event
and that event is tony stark becoming
iron man
he's forced to build these weapons for
an organization
and that organization was the ten rings
and there was this wonderful character
we really wanted to do something with
someday and that was chongchi
when they announced this the movie i was
really really excited
kind of tongue-in-cheek i ended up
tweeting marvel hey are we gonna talk or
what so i'm very glad i did that
he's so intense as this character
shang shi was made for simu and i could
feel his passion for it
the back story of sean is really unique
in that he discovered
that his father was this evil overlord
the brains gave our family power
he's brought back into his father's
world and has to deal with
coming face to face with him again and
this is a much meaner
and more hearted father
[Music]
and then crazy stuff happens after that
it was time for you to take your place
by my side that's not gonna happen
my heart was definitely in this project
it feels in line with
everything i believe in it is a crazy
wild
giant ride that we're gonna go on
[Applause]
everybody
[Music]
you